dans les bras de gladys une buse royal âgé de
10 ans elle souffre d'irritation aux pattes
nécessitant des bandages et une surveillance
toutes les trois semaines ans masc il ya de
l'oxygène qui arrive avec un gaz anesthésique
on va voir filer au fur et à mesure qu'elles
respirent finalement de plus en plus elle va
tranquilliser jusqu'à s'endormir complètement
l'animal est ensuite intubé et monitoring pour
surveiller sa respiration je vais mettre un petit
j'ai lé protecteur dans les yeux pour éviter de
la sécheresse parce qu'elle peut pas cligner des
yeux première étape la prise de son là on écarte
les plumes le vaisseau qu'on va vouloir voir
c'est la jugulaire qui est ici petite fille aux
bleus on va ponctionner deuxième étape de scanner
on arrive au niveau du coeur ont un petit peu
les poumons maintenant on arrive le foie qui
va apparaître petit tube digestif et les reins
qui sont ici c'est mon produira pouvoir leur
transférer dans la salle de soins tout est normal
hormis les bobos sur ses pattes c'est plutôt pas
trop mal est légèrement un beau tissu rose et
qui a comblé aussi il y avait un trou ans qui
avait été mis en avant la greffe ça va quand
même pas mal pas mal combler la croûte si on
est un petit peu ça un peu trop ça a tendance
à saigner donc on va encore là laissez donc
nous on va faire on va bien nettoyé et on veut
pas qu'ils aient de deux bactéries qui vient
de se produire ferrée au niveau de ce tissu qui
ralentirait encore là la cicatrisation donc un
petit peu de bétadine la bétadine savons là on
va leur faire des petits bandage pour protéger
les lésions au niveau des pieds avec ses petits
ronds de coton on va aller déplacer le concept va
mettre son poids au niveau de son pied on va les
déplacés l'appui pour pâques et d'appui au niveau
des croûtes pour pas que ce soit un désagréable
pour elle et puis aussi pour ça permettre de
d'avoir une guérison plus rapide après plus d'une
heure elle reprend ses esprits tout doucement